like many state employees correctional
officers will be getting a raise the
head of a union representing the
officers working inside Nevada prisons
calls the raise for them historic
this is by far the biggest raise that
ndoc has ever experienced for officers
so we're hopeful that that will
at least Abate the Staffing crisis and
start to get us back building the the
department back to where it needs to be
as the eight news now investigators have
been reporting Nevada prisons are
frequently on lockdown there's been
escalating violence and there have been
several attacks against officers and
between inmates the department has had a
tough time keeping and attracting
employees due to the pay rate which
hasn't been competitive with other
agencies Union president Paul lundquitz
who you just heard from there says
officers will get a 23 percent raise in
July and 4 percent next July he's hoping
an additional bill which would reduce
the amount pulled from paychecks for the
state pension program known as pers will
also pass